so we're going to return to our
one-dimensional elastic collision with
no external forces so we have object one
moving with velocity V one initial and
object to maybe it's moving this way
with the two initial I hat again on a
frictionless surface and we'll call that
our initial state and here you can
imagine we're going to use a ground
reference frame so both objects are
moving and our final state has object
one well we don't know again which way
it's going we can just say it bounced
back and object two also bounced back
but the goal of our problem of course is
to determine these vectors and by
knowing the vectors we know which way
they go now because energy and momentum
are constant let's write down our two
equations and I'm going to write them
down again in terms of components so we
have one-half m1 v1 X initial squared
plus one-half m2 v2 X initial squared
equals one-half m1 v1 X final squared
plus one-half m2 v2 X final squared now
we're going to do some algebraic
manipulations here so the first thing
I'm going to do is just eliminate these
halves because it's not necessary and I
don't want to rewrite this equation and
this is our constant fact that our
energy is constant and now our condition
that momentum is constant we'll write
this now I'm going to leave a little
space here intentionally and our
condition that momentum is constant is
m1 the X initial plus m2 v2 X initial
equals m1 the 1x final plus m2 v2 X
final now this energy equation can be
factored in by bringing all the m1 terms
to one side
- turns to the other side so when I
write that I'll need a little room I
have M 1 V 1 X initial squared minus V 1
X final square and that's equal to M to
be 2x final squared minus V 2 X initial
squared so I've just brought those terms
over the other side now likewise I'll do
the same thing down here I have M 1 V 1
X initial minus V 1 X final and that's
equal to M 2 V 2 X final minus V 2 X
initial now here comes the algebraic
trick in which I'm going to linearize
these systems this is a squared minus B
squared which factors into a plus B
times a minus B so let's give ourselves
a little room and one you want X initial
plus let's put the minus sign first
minus b 1x final times V 1 X initial
plus V 1 X final factored that term we
have the same factoring on the other
side so it's just identical the 2x final
minus V 2 X initial times the 2x final
plus B 2 X initial now let's call this
equation 1 a and our momentum factored
as 2a
now if you notice the momentum piece is
appearing exactly there and exactly here
so when I divide 1 a by 2a and I'll just
symbolically represent that then these
two pieces cancel and that leads to just
this term equal to that term and the
significance as you'll see when I write
it out 1/2 x 1x final equals V 2x final
v2x initial I've solved the quad I've
eliminated the square terms linearized
the system now I still want to write
this equation in another way another
important point to notice is that this
equation is independent of mass now what
I want to do is write this in terms of
those concepts of relative velocity we
had remember just to motivate this the
relative by definition was v1 minus v2
so let's write this in terms of the
initial and the final so in order to do
that we have to bring this initial term
over to here and this final term over to
there and so this equation which will
give it a number three and now we'll
modify that by calling it 3a we have v1
X initial minus b2 X initial now notice
the sign I'm going to want to keep the
order of one and two so I have to put a
minus sign
v1 X final minus the 2x final
and when written this way this is the
font this is the initial component of
the relative velocity and in there is
the final component of relative velocity
so by combining these two equations I
have this remarkable result that the
relative initial is minus the relative
final and this condition is a very
powerful tool for simply analyzing one
dimensional elastic inelastic collisions
I'd like to even give this a name I like
to call it the energy momentum equation
now there's a lot of significant things
about this so let's just think about it
for a moment we have that V relative
initial in magnitude is equal to the
relative final and so right away this
gives us some insight into any collision
we can see whether a collision if we
know what the relative initial velocity
is we know that the final relative
velocity has the same magnitude but
simply switches direction and that's a
powerful tool in which to analyze
collisions without doing a lot of
algebra